un líquido hierve cuando sus moléculas
tienen suficiente energía para liberarse
de la atracción existente entre esas
moléculas y a las atracciones entre
moléculas se les conoce como fuerzas
inter moleculares comparemos dos
moléculas ventano en la izquierda y
hexano en la derecha
ambos son hidrocarburos lo que significa
que sólo contienen hidrógeno y carbono
el penta no tiene 5 carbonos 1 2
455 carbonos para el pantano y el
pantano tiene un punto de ebullición de
36 grados centígrados el hexano tiene 6
carbonos 12
carbonos y un punto de ebullición más
elevado de 69 grados centígrados
dibujemos otra molécula de pantano aquí
tenemos 5 carbonos
pensemos en las fuerzas internos leku
lares que existen entre esas dos
moléculas de penta no el penta no es una
molécula no polar
y sabemos que la única fuerza inter
molecular que existe entre dos moléculas
no polares serán por supuesto las
fuerzas
d
dónde
las fuerzas de dispersión de london
existen entre estas dos moléculas de
penta no las fuerzas de dispersión de
london son las fuerzas internos leku
lares más débiles la atracción entre
moléculas sólo existe por un pequeño
periodo de tiempo así que puedo
representar las fuerzas de dispersión
del hondo de esta manera
estoy mostrando las fuerzas breves de
atracción entre estas dos moléculas de
ventana
si dibujo otra molécula de hexano por
aquí dibujaré otra el hexano es un
hidrocarburo más grande con una mayor
área superficial y una mayor área
superficial significa que tenemos una
mayor oportunidad para las fuerzas de
dispersión de london
puedo mostrar incluso más atracción
entre estas dos moléculas de hexano las
dos moléculas de hexano se atraen mucho
más entre ellas que las dos moléculas de
penta no el incremento en la atracción
significa que las moléculas necesitan
más energía para poderse separar más
energía significa un mayor punto de
ebullición el hexano tiene un punto de
ebullición más alto que el pantano
mientras incrementa el número de
carbonos en tu cadena de carbonos
obtienes un incremento en el punto de
ebullición de tu compuesto este es un
ejemplo comparando dos moléculas que
tienen cadenas lineales ahora comparemos
una cadena lineal con un hidrocarburo
ramificado aquí abajo en la izquierda
una vez más tenemos al pantano con un
punto de ebullición de 36 grados
centígrados escribamos su fórmula
molecular ya sabemos que hay
5 carbonos y si contamos los hidrógenos
hay 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 y 12 hay 12 hidrógenos h
65 h 12 es la fórmula molecular para el
pantano y qué pasa con el neo pantano en
la derecha hay 123
carbonos y
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y 12 hidrógenos
c 5 h 12 estos dos compuestos tienen la
misma fórmula molecular la misma fórmula
molecular c 5 h 12 la diferencia es que
el cne o venta no tiene ramificaciones
el 90 no tiene ramificaciones mientras
que el penta no no es una cadena lineal
bien pensamos en los puntos de
ebullición el punto de ebullición del
penta no es de 36 grados centígrados el
del 90 no baja hasta 10 grados
centígrados intentemos descubrir la
razón si dibujo otra molécula de penta
no
apenas hablamos de que las fuerzas de
dispersión de london existen entre estas
dos moléculas de ventana así que déjame
dibujar las fuerzas de atracción
transitorias entre esas moléculas el 90
no es también un hidrocarburo es no
polar si dibujo otra molécula de 90 no
pienso en las fuerzas de atracción entre
estas dos moléculas de nheo pentano y
nuevamente deben de ser fuerzas de
dispersión de london debido a estas
ramificaciones la forma del neo pantano
en tres dimensiones parece una esfera es
sólo una aproximación pero si puedes
imaginar esta molécula de neo pentano en
la izquierda es una esfera es esférica y
solo intenta imaginar esta molécula de
90 no en la derecha casi esférica y si
piensas en el área superficial para la
atracción entre estas dos moléculas es
un área mucho más pequeña que las dos
moléculas de penta no pusimos las dos
moléculas de penta no una encima de la
otra aumentando el área superficial e
incrementando las fuerzas de atracción
pero estas dos moléculas del 90 no
debido a su forma debido a estas
ramificaciones no obtenemos tanta área
superficial y eso significa que hay una
disminución
fuerzas de atracción entre las moléculas
de nheo ventana y ya que las fuerzas de
atracción disminuyen eso hace más bajo
el punto de ebullición por lo que el
punto de ebullición baja hasta 10 grados
centígrados había pensado en la
temperatura
como un valor muy cercano a 25 grados
centígrados la mayoría de las veces la
ves entre 20 y 25 pero si la temperatura
ambiente está muy cerca a 25 grados
centígrados piensa en el estado de la
materia del cne o venta no la
temperatura ambiente es mayor al punto
de ebullición del cne o pentano por lo
que a temperatura ambiente y a presión a
ambiente el cne o penta no es un gas
las moléculas ya tienen suficiente
energía para separarse las unas de las
otras el 90 no es un gas a temperatura y
presión ambiente mientras que si ves al
penta no el penta no tiene un punto de
ebullición de 36 grados centígrados el
cual es mayor que la temperatura
ambiente no hemos alcanzado el punto de
ebullición del pantano lo que significa
que a temperatura ambiente y presión
ambiente el penta no aún es un
el penta no es un líquido y pensamos en
la tendencia para las ramificaciones
aquí
el mismo número de carbonos el mismo
número de hidrógenos pero tenemos
diferentes puntos de ebullición el 90 no
tiene más ramificaciones y un punto de
ebullición más bajo podemos decir que
nuestra tendencia aquí es que mientras
aumenta mientras aumentas ra
acá yo es
y no estamos hablando del número de
carbonos aquí solo estamos hablando de
ramificaciones mientras aumentan las
ramificaciones disminuye el punto de
ebullición
porque disminuye el área superficial
para las fuerzas de atracción comparemos
tres moléculas más para terminar esto
veamos estas tres moléculas veamos si
podemos explicar estos tres puntos de
ebullición diferentes nuevamente hemos
ya hablado de el hexano con un punto de
ebullición de 69 grados centígrados si
dibujamos otra molécula de hexano
nuestras únicas fuerzas inter
moleculares son por supuesto las fuerzas
de dispersión de london así que solo
escribiré aquí los dos las fuerzas de
dispersión de london que existen entre
estas dos moléculas de hexano no polares
luego veamos tres ex zanon a el hexano
tiene 6 carbonos al igual que 3 ex zanon
a 1 todos
456 no te preocupes por el nombre de
estas moléculas en este momento si
apenas estás empezando con química
orgánica solo intenta pensar cuáles
fuerzas inter moleculares están
presentes en este vídeo 3 hexano na
también tiene 6 carbonos y déjame
dibujar otra molécula de 3 ex zanon a
ahí está nuestra otra molécula pensemos
en electro negatividad y comparemos este
oxígeno con este carbono de aquí el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
carbono
el oxígeno tendrá una mayor densidad
electrónica y se vuelve parcialmente
negativo este carbono de aquí este
carbono entonces se volverá parcialmente
positivo y entonces este es un dipolo
tenemos un dipolo para esta molécula y
tenemos el mismo dipolo
para esta molécula tres ex zanon a aquí
abajo oxígeno parcialmente negativo
carbón o parcialmente positivo y ya que
carga supuesta se atraen el oxígeno
parcialmente negativo es atraído al
carbón o parcialmente positivo en la
otra molécula de 3 ex zanon a qué fuerza
inter molecular es esa tenemos dipolos
interactuando con dipolos esta será una
interacción dipolo dipolo déjame
escribir eso por aquí
estamos hablando de una interacción
fue lo
fue lo obviamente las fuerzas de
dispersión de london estarán también
presentes si piensas en esta área de
aquí puedes pensar en fuerzas de
dispersión del honding pero dipolo
dipolo es una fuerza inter molecular
mayor comparada con las fuerzas de
dispersión de london y debido a eso las
dos moléculas aquí en 3 hexano na se
atraen entre ellas mismas más que las
dos moléculas de hexano y entonces
tomará más energía para que estas
moléculas se separen unas de otras y es
por eso que ves un punto de ebullición
más alto 3 sex and on a tiene un punto
de ebullición mucho más alto que el
hexano y eso es porque las interacciones
dipolo dipolo son fuerzas inter
moleculares mucho más grandes comparadas
con las fuerzas de dispersión de london
y finalmente tenemos tres ex zanon aquí
en la derecha la cual también tiene 6
carbonos
1 2 3
456 aún estamos tratando con 6 carbonos
si dibujo otra molécula de 3 sex and all
y déjame hacer eso aquí arriba dibujamos
los 6 carbonos y luego tenemos aquí
nuestro oxígeno y el hidrógeno de esta
manera sabemos que hay oportunidad para
enlaces de hidrógeno el oxígeno es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno por lo
que el oxígeno es parcialmente negativo
y el hidrógeno es parcialmente positivo
lo mismo ocurre aquí con la otra
molécula de 3 exhaló carga parcialmente
negativa en el oxígeno y parcialmente
positiva en el hidrógeno los enlaces de
hidrógeno son posibles déjame dibujar
eso tenemos un enlace de hidrógeno justo
aquí
hay oportunidades para enlaces de
hidrógeno entre dos moléculas de tres ex
zanon y déjame resaltarlo con azul ahora
estamos hablando de
la 6
pero
y sabemos que los enlaces de hidrógeno
sabemos que los enlaces de hidrógeno son
solo una clase más fuerte de interacción
dipolo dipolo los enlaces de hidrógeno
son las fuerzas intermón oculares más
fuertes y entonces tenemos una fuerza de
atracción elevada manteniendo a estas
dos moléculas de 3 hexano juntas
y entonces se requiere incluso más
energía de estas moléculas para
separarse y eso se refleja en el punto
de ebullición elevado para el 3 ex zanon
3 sex and all tiene un punto de
ebullición mayor que 3 sexan ona y
también mayor que el del ex ano cuando
intentes descifrar puntos de ebullición
piensa en las fuerzas internos leku
lares que están presentes entre dos
moléculas y eso te permitirá saber cuál
compuesto tiene el punto de ebullición
más alto